you are not a family man you are a
Serial adulterer who won't stop effing
lying about your own children you are
not a you are not a Christian as far as
I aware you've never stepped foot in a
church brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give 1010 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing D that you want to do but
we turn it into a money-making machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys asalam Alum guys hope you guys are
well inah so ELO musk son/daughter SLR
um daughter trans girl I don't know what
you want to call it uh for that matter
has come out blasting his or her father
for that matter um I don't know what you
want to call it I'm going to stick to
his his actual biological agenda which
is that it's is a boy I don't mean any
offense to anybody I'm just going to
stick to that I think I have a right to
speak about that here's what he had to
say this is a picture that's been shared
Elon Musk is showing that he's happy
he's like yeah all my five boys are
happy but he came out blasting him man
for some OD reason he's got some truth
to this why not because of me disliking
Elon Musk but there's some truth to
which we're going to come because it
seems like everybody's turned to become
a Christian all of a sudden from Elon
Musk to Richard Dawkin the flipping
cultural Christian he would rather
celebrate Christmas Even though doesn't
he doesn't believe in it but his said is
better than celebrating Eid and then
you've got the likes of Jordan Peterson
and Absolut flipping who's
claiming to be Christian doesn't believe
in anything and then you got Tommy
Robinson and uh the rest of the whole
team and I mean if the funding is so
good even a puss's wife has become a
Christian all of a sudden yes you know
I'm sure she believes in the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit or since shall I
say the Father the Son and the Holy
money yes anyways so here is what the
son had to say look I don't know if you
are gen if you genuinely believe this or
if you live in your own delusional
fantasy fantasy land and frankly I don't
care it seems to me like you're trying
to rebuild your brand image as a caring
paternal father which I will not let go
unchallenged if I'm going to be honest
this is absolutely pathetic you just
don't stop lying about me in interviews
books social media Etc thank God you're
an absolute absolutely terrible at it
because otherwise this would be
significantly more difficult like Neo
Marxist communist who was brainwashed at
high school to be trans and think being
rich is evil is the best way you could
go with really like really if you are
going to lie about me why would you
choose a method so obvious in its stupid
stupidity it's beyond stupid it's
desperate the fact anyone believed this
for even 5 seconds is beyond me not to
mention going out of your way to
misgender me which is both completely
transparent and and honestly just sad I
understand your new angle is this your W
is this Western value slch Christian
family man thing but it's such a weird
choice you are not a family man you're a
Serial adulterer who won't stop aing
lying about your own children you are
not a you are not a Christian as far as
I am aware you've never stepped foot in
a church you are not some Bastian for
equality SL Pro progress you called
Arabic the language of enemy when I was
six have been sued for discrimination
multiple times and are from an aparti
South Africa so anyways it goes and go
on on on on on the point is the
following yeah you can see very clearly
guys which is what you see a pattern
like I said before they are all now
trying to suit in the far right all of
them have become Christian goers you
don't even step have step foot in the
church you don't even believe it yes you
just jumping on this bandwagon and it's
very very clear if there is anything you
are Antichrist I mean anti-christian you
know you know Antichrist yes you've
actually dressed up as one before so you
don't believe in any of this stuff okay
it's very clear you the fact that you
even deem the Arabic language and enemy
language or enemy tongue or whatever it
is for that matter speaks volumes the
point is what all of these individuals
from Tommy Robinson to Elon mus to
Dawkins to even ap's wife yes and the
rest Jordan Peterson why because they
have no choice they've realized that
atheism has come and took the faith of
all the Christians millions of them in
Europe you'll never see anything that in
history of Islam tooken all of their
faith away made them atheist they've
become morally bankrupt spiritually
bankrupt Islam has come and given them a
solution which works which is pragmatic
and it works spiritually elevating them
thousands of people are coming to Islam
especially after the Palestine issue we
are seeing it in our da tables which you
guys can fund brother and sister there's
a link here in we would really
appreciate or whatever you give to help
fund our da tables and I'm a trusty I
don't get sing paid a single penny so
the point is what that you can see now
that the movement is going towards that
angle they have all become Christian
they have all become individuals who are
going to the church all of them have one
thing in common and that is hating Islam
people are flocking to Islam and they
have realized that Islam is the solution
and they are all scared of what as
Muslims are taking over taking over how
how will we going to take over the only
thing we want to do is what spread the
message of Islam isn't that freedom of
speech and if that freedom of speech equ
to people come into Islam and if people
come to Islam equates Islam equates that
the majority of the population of the
European countries become Muslim this
happened with the freedom of choice of
the freedom of expression and they're
making the freedom of choice of religion
and you are so fearful of that that's
the reason why you are turning to
violence and guess what the prophet
Muhammad peace upon him's lifetime tells
us the same exact thing that's happened
to him freedom of speech to preach Islam
they didn't like it they lied they lied
about him they tried to belittle him
mock him and then they turn to violence
when they realize Islam is spreading and
that is exactly what is going on today
with the race riots that's exactly
what's going on every everyone has
become Christian flipping Tommy
Robertson the CID prostitute flipping
sleeps with prostitutes cheats on his
wife every second day use charity money
money for Coke and you can see that this
man is coming and talking about
Christianity and church and Jesus are
you kidding me Muslims are the ones at
the Forefront defending Jesus they at
the forefronts when it comes to
transgenderism being shoved down our
kids throat that's all I have to say El
musk's son has or daughter however he
wants to be gender himself has exposed
his own own father that's all I want to
say in